It's an exciting time.
The new horizons space probe is flying past Pluto
and the astronomers wild with excitement, new canyons,
all sorts of things on Pluto,
binary excited for different reason because new horizons
is carrying plutonium.
So the element plutonium is going to the planet. Pluto,
how much better can you get than that? The three elements,
uranium neptunium and plutonium were named
after the three planets in those days,
Pluto was still considered to be a planet.
So uranium had been called uranium for a long time.
And when they discovered the new elements, 93 and 94,
it was natural to call them after Neptune and Pluto.
The reason why the new horizons has plutonium
on it is because they need energy.
Usually spacecraft that are near the earth,
or even a bit further away on Mars have large
arrays of solar panels,
like the PV panels that some people have on their houses, but of course,
much lighter and more efficient.
And they just use the sunlight to generate
electricity. But when you get to Pluto,
it's far too far away from the sun to get useful amounts of light.
In fact, if you stood on Pluto,
the sun would just look like a rather large star.
You wouldn't notice the sunlight at all or very little.
So you need some other sorts.
Of energy and lift off of NASA's new horizons spacecraft on a decade,
visit the planet Pluto, and then beyond by far the most.
Wait effective energy source, uh, radioactive sources,
as you know,
the most powerful bombs are nuclear bombs where you release all the
energy in a fraction,
a tiny fraction of a second plutonium is used
on spacecraft to release the thermal
energy that comes from radio active decay.
You have a lump or a series of pieces of the
isotype of plutonium plutonium two, three eight.
This is not the same isotope that is used for nuclear
weapons,
but it is one that decays at a rather slower rate
spontaneously.
You don't need neutrons to set it off and to get the chain reaction.
And it decays with a half-life of
87.7 years. So it slowly decays away.
But if you have a lump of this material,
quite a sizable lump the energy it's producing,
heats it up till it's nearly red hot,
and then you can surround it by thermocouples,
which will convert the thermal energy,
the heat energy into electricity, or to electrical energy.
How do you just turn hate into pure electrical energy?
Well, people are quite often familiar with thermocouples that used to measure
temperature where you have two different metals, um,
in contact. And when you heat them up, you generate a small voltage,
which is usually put onto some sort of digital display that shows the
temperature. However, if you have thick wires,
you can generate quite a reasonable current.
And if you have lots of these thermal couples arranged in suitably,
you can generate a reasonable voltage as well.
So just the pure hate is shunting electrons along the way.
Yes,
the energy that they get out for the new horizons,
they have 10.9 kilos of plutonium.
That's quite a serious amount of plutonium. Of course it's a different isotope,
but it's nearly twice as much as the plutonium that was in the atom bomb that
destroyed Nagasaki. So it's serious amount of plutonium.
This 10.9 kilos is producing about
280 Watts,
which is enough to light a couple of powerful light bulbs of the old salt.
And there's enough to power everything on the spacecraft.
The plutonium is decaying all the time.
So it's taken nine or nearly 10 years for new horizons to
get to Pluto. And during that time,
the power will live decade because there is less heat coming out of the
plutonium, but there's still enough to power all the instruments.
In fact,
there was a delay launching the new horizons and that also made
the power pack lose some of its power. If it had been on time,
they would have had considerably more power,
but they have very clever power management
techniques. So all being well.
There's enough to get the great pictures back that we're looking forward to the
power pack, I think is quite big. And it's very carefully constructed.
The plutonium is in the form of plutonium oxide,
which is surrounded by Iridium,
which is the metal that has almost the highest melting point of any metal.
And then that is again, surrounded by graphite.
And the whole thing then is put in contact with thermocouples.
It weighs quite a large amount,
but in terms of kilowatt hours,
per kilo of weight,
it is fantastically better than say using petrol or
gasoline to power the satellite.
So it's a very high energy density. The trial for chemistry is that,
well, I think physicists would claim those nuclear power.
So it was really theirs,
but what I really like is plutonium going to Pluto. Now,
obviously we don't have any plutonium here.
You may have seen our videos just to go in and look at a few milligrams.
We had to dress up all the specialists. However,
I do have my plutonium coffee mat.
And in this test tube here, I have a soft drink,
which calls itself plutonium.
And what is important to say is that if this was
really plutonium, two, three, eight oxide,
this test tube would be too hot to touch plutonium. Two,
three eight is made synthetically.
It is made from uranium,
which is turned into neptunium element
93. And that element 93,
then decays into plutonium two, three eight, if the carries up,
yes, it decays up because it,
there is a BTK and emission of an electron,
which essentially is a neutron turning into a proton it's quite a
difficult process to do.
And you need very special reactor to convert uranium to neptunium
and then get the final stage. It used to be manufactured in the United States.
They've now stopped. And the us space program bought some plutonium, two,
three, eight from Russia,
but now even those stocks are running out and we're talking about really
small amounts of this material, 20 kilos, something like that.
So as far as I know, there is some plutonium, two, three eight,
available in the States for the next Mars Rover.
Because for these Mars rovers,
the vehicles that go around Mars,
you can't really power them with solar panels because you'd need huge
solar panels to get enough power.
And so it really would not be able to drag all these things behind them,
but there is a sorted.
And there's a question is it's very expensive to make this plutonium two,
three eight.
And in the current time of tight budgets,
it's been decided it's not economic to do it.
Professor. Oh, I can imagine if an element was named after.
A person who was later disgraced on an international scale,
that our you pack would consider changing the name of the element.
I think they would do that.
Do you think there's a case to be made for changing the name of plutonium?
Because it was named after a Grande planet and the planet was famously demoted.
Does that mean we should demote the element name too?
Definitely not because it's not Pluto's fault that
we've changed the definition. It hasn't misbehaved.
Hasn't thrown rocks at the earth or anything like that. I never,
I think it's many people think Pluto has been pretty hard done by they'd be
uproar if plutonium was renamed. And anyway,
then there'd be big arguments. What we should call it.
I think I'm very happy with the name and your suggestion is right.
I think Pluto should still be a planner. Yeah.